you I look at you you have a great
childhood and your great husband and
father I assume I'm not your children
but how do you
find that place and where do you go to
when you snap when you become that guy
in Whiplash when you become Jessup when
you become when that moment comes how do
you go into that dark place and did you
ever experience such darkness that that
helped you with that moment or those
moments you know I I honestly I think
however you know
easy and and privileged and and and full
of love you know your childhood and and
your life is we all have difficulties we
all have disappointments we all have
things that you know break our hearts or
piss us off you know we all have things
uh that we're you know uh uh an anger I
think that we carry around to some
extent the the um the common thread
and people who shake their heads at this
but between those three characters that
you mentioned and and what is what is to
me so important as an actor almost
always
is that for for lieutenant colonel
Nathan Jessup and A Few Good Men uh for
Fletcher and Whiplash uh for Vern
Schillinger and Oz
those incredibly deeply angry powerful
men
with their powerful emotions it all
comes out of love
however Twisted that love may be you
know in Vern Schillinger's place it's
like boy I love me some white people
you know I mean I mean that's the way he
views his his philosophy his world view
you know yeah not not that I hate this
that I love that you know in internal
jessup's place so brilliantly
brilliantly written you know unit core
God country that's what he loves in that
order
and that's what motivates everything he
does including you know
the illegal you know uh dangerous you
know horrible immoral stuff and the
justification for it it's uh it it's
always you know uh Fletcher loves
Jazz so much
and is seeking Perfection every second
of his Waking Life that when anybody or
anything gets in the way of that you
know his love for that
then they're gonna buy God here about it
have you ever really snapped like one of
these characters in real life have you
ever lost your mind uh I
a few times mostly when I'm in the car
by myself on the 101.
um